Right now, we're gonna look at lighting
with Intamin Motion.
Now again, we're not gonna cover in depth
as much as we will in later courses.
However, let's get a little bit started
so you can get familiarized
and start playing around with the lighting
to really get a good feel for it.
And as you can imagine, lighting is very important
because it does set up the mood
of what you're trying to convey.
So again, what mood are you going for?
You need to ask yourself that before anything.
If it's an outside scene
or a scene that's affected by the outside,
such as our lake house,
you may want to see how things are affected at nighttime.
So you could change the time of day
as part of the ambiance settings.
And it will affect the entire scene.
So that's what's kind of nice.
You'll get some natural reflections on the inside,
which can give you an idea of,
you know, like the color of your walls
or how the fabric may look differently at night
compared to during the day.
But again, we're just gonna kind of mess around
with a little bit of lighting
just so you can get an idea of what is there.
And then we'll kind of move on from there.
So what we're gonna do
is we are gonna access the lights via the library,
and we're gonna place a spotlight into the scene,
one or two, or maybe even three.
And then we can go over
and play around with the temperatures.
Now there are some other ones
that are available to us as well.
So let's go ahead and hop right back in
to our Twinmotion scene.
And I've already got it highlighted
on these three lights that are a little head over.
And you'll see right now we do have a spotlight.
Now you can rename it if you wish to,
like you come over here
and maybe put the left and center and right.
But right now I'm just gonna leave it
to kind of keep it simple.
And you'll see over here to the right,
we do have ways to add some haze
and different color temperatures.
Now right now it is set at 4613 kelvins,
which is a warmer temperature,
but you could cool it down and change it through here.
And you'll see that overall effect later
when we are activating our scene.
But right now let's just go ahead
and find where those lights are.
Come over here to the library,
look for lights, and you'll see spotlight.
Now you may also see some neon lights,
which you could put over the kitchen.
You could do an omni-direction,
which will give you a nice overall glow,
but you'll also notice these IES.
These are profiles that are pretty standardized lighting.
So a lot of the settings have already been set up for us
so it would be more likely that we'll use these
when you are working
with more specific architectural lighting.
So just be aware that that's what those are for.
But we're just gonna go ahead and grab a spotlight.
Just kind of place it wherever we want.
I mean, you can place it anywhere that you'd like to,
but I'm just gonna go ahead
and kind of place it right there.
And it may not be exactly where you want it,
in which case is fine.
You can just kind of pull that right up into there
and kind of get in a little closer.
And remember, you can always snap to a surface.
You don't want to kind of snap right in there.
Kind of gets a little picky sometimes.
But yeah, just get as close to the area
that you want in that bulb.
So we can also do a really cool thing about duplicating.
So if you're adding a lot of lights
or say multiple chairs like what's down there,
there's multiple ways to create that.
You could just drag and drop another one,
or you could hold down your Control, Shift
and drag this over.
You have to kind of get that little guy there,
but as you see, it will now create a duplicate.
But you'll also get some options here.
You can do it as an instance,
in which case any changes that you make
to one of the other lights,
it's part of that instance,
which would be just this guy.
You could leave it at instance,
or you could do it as a copy.
Now the copy will keep it separate
so you can change things regardless of,
like the lighting, the cone, the temperature.
You could do those individually.
So if that's what you're wanting to do, great.
But it's really great for the example
of changing out chairs.
For example, you'd want them instances
because then you could change them all out.
So if you replace the material of one,
it replaces the material of all of the chairs.
So just keep that in mind.
I'm going to go ahead and leave it as an instance,
and I only need one,
but see you can even adjust the spacing.
So let's say you want to have them staggered out.
You can have multiple staggered out.
That could be like picket fences or anything like that.
So any object that you control shift and drag
will give you this copy option.
So I'm just going to leave everything as default.
Just go ahead and let that go.
And we'll go ahead and change over here.
We're going to change the color temperature.
And you will notice that when you come over here
to the light,
it too will have the same color temperature
because it is an instance.
However, this one will have a different one
and we could change this into really warm.
Coming back to here,
you'll see that these two will have the same.
So that's the great thing about copying with an instance.
So keep that in mind.
Go ahead and go around in your scene
and kind of play around.
We'll put this up to five on the speed
so I can zoom in on out a little quicker
and you'll see some really great objects
in which you can swap out
or even change the furniture itself,
but have some fun.
That's what you want to do here.
So let's take a look back
into our little PowerPoint here real quick
and you can see all the settings that are available to you
but next we are going to explore seasons.
So we can change the time of day,
but also we can change it to snowing on the outside.
Let's hop right in.